okay this guy searched up NBA scores I
like this okay this is good this is a
good song this is a green or maybe he's
like betting on sport he either has six
figures he's six foot tall if he plays
basketball oh that's a good point maybe
he has a six because oh speech to surf
in New York he's really oh my God he
definitely has to attack okay
well then he has so much free time that
means I have no money a Chinese
restaurant yeah so if he took you there
would you be impressed if he pays yes
I don't make six figures though right
daylight savings it means he's very on
top of his schedule he'll be on time I
feel like Pomeranian lifespan so he
likes dogs okay green flag I'm thinking
about adopting a dog right okay does
melatonin give nightmares so he's a
night owl it means he has a serious um
insomnia it's just hard to fall asleep
sometimes this is a great candidate
wholesome really nice sporty they're all
good things this is so nice